c'est un des jugements les plus attendus
de new york les caméras braquées sur la
soeur de ghislaine maxwell après cinq
jours de délibérations difficile
la femme mondaine britannique est
reconnu coupable de cinq chefs
d'accusation sur six dont exploitation
et trafic sexuel de femmes mineures de
1994 à 2004 elle a attiré des
adolescentes pour qu'elle soit agressée
sexuellement par son conjoint le
milliardaire jeffry obstine ils ont mené
pendant des années un train de vie
luxueux les faits reprochés à maxwell se
seraient déroulés dans les résidences du
milliardaire en floride à new york et au
nouveau mexique le couple a développé au
fil du temps des amitiés avec plusieurs
personnalités dont le prince andrew lui
aussi éclaboussés par cette affaire
baptisée
mène
quatre femmes dont trois sous pseudonyme
ont témoigné au procès ce qui a rendu
possible le verdict d'aujourd'hui a
souligné le procureur
l'avocate de maxwell ne compte pas en
rester là
ghislaine maxwell est passible de 65 ans
de prison en détention depuis l'été 2020
elle sera donc la seule à payer pour ses
crimes son ex-conjoint jeffrey epstein
s'est suicidé en 2019 dans une prison en
attente de son procès
ici même josé maria mourani
[Musique]
donc